c'est non non alors il paraît que vous
allez être le prochain pdg de tf1
non le directeur des programmes de la
direccte indépendament c'est pas sûr sur
ses pas sur sûr mais comment dire je vis
avec un responsable socialiste qui est
beaucoup plus qu'un camarade pour moi
soi même et par ce biais souvent si je
pense que l'on va me confier bientôt la
direction du programme qu'elle est déjà
là j'ai apporté un chemin de oui c'est
un brouillon pour l'instant je pense
être d'abord il faut faire baisser les
coûts des deux autres chaînes en
utilisant la calomnie par exemple propos
de pierre desgraupes par exemple on peut
dire que pierre desgraupes c'est un
homme d'argent il est en effet les
missions médicales il parle énormément
de l'aspirine ou ses remarques et il
touche sur le oui à oui tous énormément
d'argent abus si t'es con et signe sur
sur l'aspirine et il va avec ça il va
voir les filles avec makowsky enfin je
vous raconte comme sur fr3 aussi et on
peut faire baisser les pots de fer 3 en
parlant un peu plus de séveno maurice
eveno c'est quelqu'un qui a été viré de
la télévision pour indépendance
vis-à-vis du pouvoir et qui a été
réintégrée pour dépendance loris arnaud
est le fils caché de tixier vignancour
et nicole questiaux à boom l'esprit que
son côté pur et dur qui lui vient de son
père et le côté bigot qui vient de
s'achever
d'autre part pour faire baisser les
coûts des deux autres chaînes il
faudrait leur piquer leurs bonnes idées
l'idée la plus comique de d'antenne 2
c'est le journal des sourds et
malentendants
moi j'ai instituerait plutôt sur tf1
journal pas un journal des comptes des
dons comprenant vue qui a déjà sévi au
niveau chant mais on dirait si on
s'amuse bien notre sort alors su de ciu
qui venait parler de du drame des
minorités américaines en fin mai six
chevaux complet veston c'est qu'il
voulait plus du tout oui bien sûr
c'était bien honorable qui voulait plus
qu'on les prenne pour des pour des
clowns avec des plumes
ils ont expliqué ça pendant dix minutes
et à la fin on leur a dit merci beaucoup
monsieur elles ont fini ensemble le
calumet de la paix ces réunions
elle a dû leur faire plaisir c'est à
dire un peu non ce que je vais faire si
un journal des culottes et des noms
gambadant et puis et puis fr3 je
l'appliquerais bien l'idée de soir 3 et
qui est déjà piqué sur le journal
télévisé de radio varsovie le soir il
manque plus qu'à leur mettre des
uniformes pour que ce soit aussi rigolo
et les la joute ça je veux faire ça
madiot varsovie vous n'aviez pas tout ça
ah non et c'est pourquoi je suis content
d'être ici
il faudrait aussi créer de nouvelles
émissions sur tf1
alors je voudrais jean-edern hallier la
météo pas de janvier est une idée oui
c'est pas très intéressant mais il s'en
fout du rock on voit sa gueule c'est
tellement vrai
et puis en plus il pourra vivre a une
belle carte de france il pourrait
déplacer les petits nuages qui s'enlève
tout seul comme lui expliquer ce que je
trouvais encore sur sur tf1 je
reprendrai cd cinéma 16c cinéma 16 mai
en braille pour les aveugles
de toute façon généralement rien à voir
les films de cinéma ça c'est pas
d'intérêt sans droit de réponse je ferai
une deuxième émission derrière qui
s'appellerait droit de réponse à droit
de réponse cet été
oui c'est pour donner la parole aux gens
qui sont à l'émission de plaques qui
n'ont rien à dire mais qui a envie de le
dire quand même pour lui
et puis enfin le samedi après-midi
j'améliorais encore si faire se peut les
missions de sédouy qui fait que c'est
une très bonne émission et reggae c'est
surtout très gai les jeunes adorent ça
c'est des jeunes des jeunes neveux qui
s'est vraiment ils m'ont dit que c'était
aussi aussi rigolo que qu'une brochette
de responsables de l'armée rouge le jour
le 1er mai pourrait être encore plus
drôle devrait faire danser le reggae
made in france
donc je pense faire des idées et puis
pour terminer je voudrais surtout
continuer la politique d'alternance qui
a cours sur tf1 et m par exemple 14 ans
danièle gilbert six mois d'un sinclair
14 merci tu verras c'est vital en 2002
sacré programme
mon avis oui croyez vraiment qu'il y
aurait des chances avec un programme pas
je le ferais rire je pense que si c'est
douillet a été entendu il va me
pistonner annick beauchamp aussi oui
donc vous êtes encore fait des copains
je pense j'ai bon espoir
vous avez l'intention de travailler à la
télévision l'année prochaine oui c'est
moi aussi c'est pas si bien sûr la
quatrième il vous a fait rire le copage
et les lunettes tout en b to b c c'est
gentil de l'avoir rendu la dernière
émission tout à fait joyeuse et non
juste content d'être là je suis très
triste que ça serait mais non mais moi
mon nez à la roue tourne c'est normal
c'est oui comme ça ce que disent les
lacs l'alternance fait que mon nom
[Musique]